which one of you would rather be forced
to carry an unwanted pregnancy to term I
would it's my own body I'm a woman if I
don't want to give birth abortion to me
is just like forced to miscarriage what
if it's not your body if it's not my
body it's not my business okay so if
that baby inside your womb is not your
body it's an autonomous human being mhm
then you don't have the right to kill it
petus is not conscious I'm going by the
definition of Consciousness if someone
is UNC theye to be a can you K them no
why not cuz it's unconscious it's not
experienced what if someone has never
had any experiences I've known people
worked with people with special needs
who are not able to experience the
outside world MH would these not count
as human experiences oh yeah it does
okay so then that's a human that you're
killing mhm